the jurogan experience you had
uh you had encounters with bob lazar
you you know bob and you you were around
when bob lazar first uh now is this
going to be all about the mylar balloon
event
what's the mylar balloon event oh you
don't know that one no
uh so we all jump in my car
to go out to the alien inn
area out there you know on the alien inn
is that uh
out there yeah it's like a north bar or
something yes
for uh north of that area and so
so bob lazar
um george knapp myself and i think jane
huff
who is bob's friend we all go out there
well i'm being honest to me
bob has a mylar balloon which really
bounces their radar signature
a lot for its size and
a bottle of gas uh helium
so uh we we find our way back out in the
desert
out there we're kind of i'm thinking
we're on a a ufo watch which is
always fun sometimes the best thing is
the food you take along
right and you're out there under the
stars and it's nice and
you have a good time just watching so
but there's a rustle of things going on
here and
next thing i know there's a balloon this
mylar balloon's inflated
and there's a slight breeze and bob lets
it go
and we're on the opposite side of the
mountain range from supposedly s4
and he wants he wants to go that way
thank god the wind was going the
opposite direction was traveling north
instead of south
and it went the wrong way you know so
i'm thinking
my life's just passed before my eyes why
do you think you'll like pass before
your eyes because if the balloon goes
towards area s4 it's going to get picked
up
yeah they're going to go find out where
it came from security is going to come
get us and i'm going to spend the night
in jail
right so you know it all just unraveled
real quick
and was this before bob had gotten in
trouble for bringing people to the
observation point
to watch because let's let's tell the
story about bob real quick bob
said he worked for area s4 and he was
hired to
back engineer what they believe were
alien crafts along
the lines he had this top secret
clearance and along the lines of all
this happening
they're monitoring his phone calls turns
out bob's wife
is having an affair bob doesn't know
about this
they removed him from the project
because they believe he'll be
emotionally unstable
if he's so he's he's freaking out not
knowing a that his wife is having an
affair not knowing why he's pulled from
this project
doesn't totally understand so starts
telling people about what he's doing
and telling people listen i can take you
to a place where once a week they do
these tests
so he starts bringing people to this
area they see these
objects flying in these spectacular ways
that we really can't do with any of our
conventional aircrafts and then bob gets
in trouble for that
then bob goes on the george knapp show
and starts explaining all these
different things presumably for
self-preservation
because he the best way to probably
protect your own life
is to go public with this and explain
everything that's happening
and they can discredit you and make you
look like a nut but if they kill you
then you know then it leads credence to
your story
yeah it gives you a very a huge hardship
so when do you kill you when do you fall
into the story
well you've just given me an overload of
information now that i'm pretty much
aware of
but i don't know exactly when i don't
think as i recall it
everybody was pretty much at ease and um
i wasn't it wasn't part of what year is
this that this is all going on oh god
um i don't know 91.
so this is around that time this is
around when was he on george knapp's
show yeah somewhere in that time frame
but i wasn't aware of a lot until much
until
i don't think at that time i was aware
of him taking people out on
you know wednesday nights to go see
something out
there i kind of missed out on that or
whatever and
um i don't think this was anything like
connected to that
i think that that was before this yeah
probably that was
i think you're dealing with him out
after you know he had met george and
after he had told the story yeah because
george is with you
oh yeah yeah so obviously they had
already met oh sure um
so what was your initial
obviously you're a person that has a
deep fascination with ufos
now here you are talking to this guy
who's clearly a genius
brilliant guy bob lazar and he's telling
you this
[ __ ] banana story he's out there back
engineering spacecrafts that came from
another land
that are that are using this element 115
this this stuff that's just a
theoretical element that wasn't even
proven by particle collider until what
2013
somewhere along that line like it was
just theoretical up to that point so
he's telling you about all this stuff
what was your what did you think
um i i
wanted to reserve judgment until i knew
a lot more
and um the more he talked
the more interesting it became the more
research that george did things that he
uncovered it became more interesting
and and so um
as i said a while back i think george
was doing an interview with me and i
said i
i wouldn't bet against bob's the truth
of the majority of of everything that
bob has said
i wouldn't bet against it could they be
arizona missions for different reasons
yeah sure that could but um
the the uh i
i would tend to say bob is
is legitimate um and
uh you know i don't there's certain
aspects of things
that are parts of stories that you
wonder well how could this happen
and so forth but i think if you if you
take all of the collective
information and the work that george
knapp has done
to validate things it's awfully damn
impressive
but george is such an important part of
it because he's a legitimate
investigative journalist
and that was his career and so he
poured himself into this oh yeah and
exposed
all the different aspects of this story
that seemed to indicate that he's
telling the truth
oh yes yeah and that's that's what's
crazy about it and george is not any
normal journalist
he is he's like what he has like six pea
bodies yes he's fantastic
and he's diving into this and the more
he uncovers the more it seems like bob
bobbles our story is legitimate right
right
so i i think until you i like
the philosophy of reserving judgment
until you have
a preponderance of evidence that really
moves you
one way or another you don't have to
have a hundred percent i go by
reasonable doubt but what was it like
for you to be this guy who's had this
deep
fascination with flying saucers and here
you are
talk let me tell you my experience with
bob doing the podcast with bob
i wanted one of two things i wanted to
go oh this guy's full of [ __ ]
or i wanted whoa this guy's
it seems like he's not full [ __ ] i think
he's telling the truth
i think this guy really did encounter
these aircrafts and really did
work on these spaceships whatever they
are that's what where i'm at right now
my experience with him my communication
with him he didn't seem like he's full
[ __ ] at all
he's clearly a brilliant guy his story
has not
changed at all over the 30 plus
years that he's been saying it it's a
crazy story
but when you're a person like yourself
me you saw me even more than i who
is obsessed with this subject this the
possibility of alien life that has
visited
visited this earth and and maybe even
left crafts behind
and maybe these crafts are in the
possession of some
secret government agencies that are
trying to observe them and back engineer
them
what is it like to talk to this guy to
this because this guy has seen the thing
you're looking for
this guy the all the you're you're
searching and
all of your wondering and staring out
into the heavens and here's a guy
that has actually touched it actually
worked on it been inside one
tried to figure out how they work can't
do it doesn't understand it
it's talking to these people
everything's compartmentalized you got
the metallurgist people that are working
on the
the what what kind of alloy this thing
is made of you got him
who's a part of the people that are
trying to understand the propulsion
system
and then you've got people that are
giving you this information that like
maybe they have uh been here forever
maybe this is a part of an
archaeological dig maybe
they've been trying to study these
things for decades with no
no advancement at all yeah so
we came across our
myself and a couple other people came
across folks
who could collaborate some of the things
going on
out there um such as
silent craft actually lifting off
at night time um not looking
as though the control was very good
but actually lifting off maneuvering
like a real
small trial kind of thing
and that fellow observed it from a
distance where he wasn't supposed to be
uh george has come up with with
collaboration i think from
two or three other sources also besides
what bob said
about certain aspects of things out
there it's just that bob's story
is so much more in depth so much more
detailed like that book
that he talked about years ago coming
across
um uh amazing things so what tell people
about the book
well there was a there was a book as i
remember
there was some kind of a book that
bob um was allowed to look through
or he actually or he sees the
opportunity to do it
when he was in a room where the book was
but i think that was by design
and it was some kind of a holographic
book
that as you opened up the pages whatever
the stories were
became a hologram that's my recollection
of a conversation that's decades old now
so um um
you know if i got it wrong fire me
that's it's you know it's
you'll have to talk to bob about that
would you or talk to george
okay and uh because i remember something
like that i mean that was like
wow what a what an amazing way
to portray information in some kind
of a book and actually have holographic
images
coming forth out of the you know i don't
know it just was
so that uh i haven't ever heard of that
being repeated any place in terms of
something else like that happening
and so much that happened to bob
it was so unique there was also some
very strange
summary of what they understand uh or
what they believe to be true
about the origins of human beings and
that they
believed that what these visitations
were about was that human beings are the
product of accelerated evolution
and that these species from wherever had
been coming here
and doing genetic experience experiments
with
primates and created human beings
which is the ultimate like who knows
like wow that's fun to think about
but we were talking about this last
night like how bizarre
humans are that out of all these things
on earth we're the only ones with shoes
and all these things we're the only ones
that have to wear clothes
we're the only ones would jump into
metal boxes with rubber tires and roll
around these hard surfaces that we
created
or flying planes or send video through
your phone to other people that are on
the other side of the continent
we're weird we're real weird we're way
weirder than anything else that exists
and if we are really a product of some
sort of accelerated process
like that this is how they get the party
started on these planets they find
semi-intelligent curious animals that
are using tools or using
you know opposable thumbs and uh
they they do some things to them
yeah they there's a large variety of
of uh potential um
beginnings um more evidence for some
than others right
so that's that's always the trick have
you considered that
is this like a subject that you've
deeply considered and thought about
not really really i'm here
i don't want to look a gift horse in the
face i'll take it for what it is
you know really yeah i mean
i think about it a lot i don't know i i
think
i need more more evidence to
be more curious about i'm more concerned
about other kinds of
things that are now than where the human
species come from particularly
i'm more driven by other kinds of things
that could make a difference today
going forward so getting back to the bob
lazar thing when you first got to know
him when you first were
considering the story and how crazy it
was what was it like
to to meet a guy who at least
by his own accounts had encountered this
thing that you were seeking
well bob's a likable guy he as you said
he's very smart
and so he's interesting to talk to right
yeah and
um and so
that's more than just entertaining to
listen to his story
is profound right so it gives you an
awful lot to think about
and to try to to
position as to how can you measure
future information you might get against
that story
how can you verify different kinds of
things and
uh so i i
i've heard a lot more silly things i
think than
then what bob was talking about didn't
seem all that
um ridiculous and then the more you get
to talk to him the more you get to know
him
and and people like george who's an
investigative journalist
it gets more and more wow
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience